okay good morning everybody it's mike
it's uh it's just coming up on um
11 a.m chicago time uh 9 a.m pacific
time and you know get started in in a
few seconds here and you know i want to
thank you for taking the time out of
your busy day
to join us
to
you know to join
in today's training on how to get your
edge in
trading in order flow right you know
every book you read on
trading always says you know you got to
find your edge
in the markets right but they don't
really tell you really how to find your
edge you know it's sort of you know a
blanket statement that you know as
traders we're always looking for that
edge and
you know in anything whether it's sports
or
you know cards or you know we're always
trying to find an edge in what we're
doing and you know that's how you become
successful in something is you you
develop a skill and you apply it so what
you're going to learn today you know is
hopefully going to come away from
today's presentation and you're going to
understand how to read the market and
reading the market isn't mo isn't um
you know so complex that oh my gosh you
know i need to have a math degree
anything like that you can you know read
the market based on what's trading right
now i'm gonna show you how to trade
smarter with order flow right you know
the old saying um
don't work harder work smarter you know
is especially true in trading and i'm
going to show you how to understand
what's happening in the market based on
what's trading right now you know
because at the end of the day
you know as a trader you got to realize
what you're trading you're trading on
the information
that is current all right you don't
necessarily be trading on information
that is
you know 15 minutes ago an hour ago
previous day's information you want to
be trading on what is happening right
now in the market
now for those of you that are new to one
of my presentations i'll just give you a
quick little brief background on who i
am and you know where i'm coming from
you know because there's a lot of people
out there on the internet you know
telling you oh this is how you trade you
know but they don't really have a
trading background right they
opened an account a couple years ago
they put a couple thousand dollars in it
you know they made twenty percent all of
a sudden now they're a guru
but you know i have you know a solid
background going back to the 1990s when
i started on the cme floor as a runner
with dean witter reynolds you know i
literally started at the bottom of the
industry and worked my way up
after leaving the cme trading floor when
electronic trading started taking off i
joined the upstairs trading desk at dean
witter and you know i was
when globex on the cme uh project a on
the cbot and nymex access started to
really become popular you know i realize
that is where
the future in the industry is right it's
going to be electronic trading and i got
to position myself because you know
that's where i want to be so i've been
trading electronically literally since
the infancy of electronic trading back
in the early 1990s
and
you know i spent three years there then
after that i joined the global macro
trading desk at edf man you know it's
the big edf man is a is a huge
english
trading company you know they've been
around since the 1700s you know trading
um you know they think they started out
in sugar and but they're they're really
trading you know anything and everything
you could imagine after that i joined
commerce bank in chicago as a licensed
ux trader
and i traded buns bobble shafts as well
as all the us contracts you know i had a
license from the
urex exchange
which you know previously was the dtb
where you know i was only one of a
handful of people outside of germany
that can actually trade um their
contracts
outside of the country right there's
only probably about you know six of us
that were in chicago and we you know we
had this license to trade um these
contracts and it was great you know
because it was like shooting fish in a
barrel and
after commerce bank after september 11th
happened you know i took about six
months off and i joined cargill in
chicago cargill the big
american trading company this time
and again you know
people don't understand how big cargill
is it's
you know the the first or second now
depending on on you know the metrics
privately held company in the united
states if it was a publicly held company
it would rank like seventh or 8th but
they literally trade everything you
could also imagine you know they account
for about 30 percent of the us grain
exports about 25 percent of the meat
exports
and
around this is around 2004 early 2004
the exchange in singapore was closing
and they wanted someone to go out there
and set up a trading desk for the off
the floor um trading activity so i moved
out to singapore
set up a trading desk there
you know it's all futures because uh you
know being in chicago we have the
futures exchanges and
eventually i left cargill and joined jp
morgan where i was vice president of
futures training for eight years right
and it was a trading
job where i'm sitting on the desk
banging away on the computer trading all
day long you know from um since it's in
singapore the globex reopen would be 6
a.m i would trade that until basically
the close of hong kong which was uh 4 15
and you know be in the office until 5.
but you know after eight years of that i
really felt you know i really felt like
i was on a treadmill and i wanted
something more to life you know i had
gotten married already um you know i had
a daughter already and
i left i left the perfectly
well-paying job at a very prestigious
company and you know i just i felt that
i already developed the skills that you
know i can do this on my own right i
don't need to
um you know work for a company to do
this i wanted the freedom and trading
gives you that freedom and around 2015 i
started up the orderflows.com which is
my company where we provide training for
traders on how to read the order flow as
well as software for traders to use to
understand the order flow
and the reason i talk about the software
is because the charts you're going to
see in this presentation are generated
from the order flows trader which is now
3.0 you know we've had the original
order flows trader which was released in
2015 we did an upgrade around
2018 and then
just last year we did another major
upgrade which is the version 3.0
now it runs on ninjatrader 8 and it's a
volume footprint chart but not just a
regular volume footprint chart you know
because you get volume footprint charts
pretty much anywhere nowadays
but this one has
ways of analyzing the order flow
that i analyze right so it's not that
you know like i said you can get
charting software
that just puts a footprint on a chart
but you know as you're going to see it's
better to have tools that are going to
it's going to help you
analyze
what you're seeing in the market because
you know unless you're
you know an experienced or a flow trader
it's going to be a little bit difficult
to
see the same things over and over and
over
and
you know we've
had three this is our third upgrade and
we've add you know every time we do an
upgrade upgrades are free but we add in
more tools for the user
so it's not just a basic footprint chart
now
honestly
i'd never set out to start a software
company but
i started writing a book after i left
morgan you know i had a lot of time on
my hands you know even though i had you
know a new daughter and you know you
think you know it's going to be busy
you know i had a lot of time on my hand
so i started writing a book on trading
specifically on trading order flow
and
you know eventually you know as i was
trading overflow myself
with other software i realized that you
know what the the software is just so
basic you know why don't i make you know
add some tools in there that can improve
my trading
analysis so that i don't have to
concentrate on so many little you know
every little tick that goes through you
know let the software lift some of that
burden off me so if you stick around to
the end i'll show you how to get a copy
of my book called trading order flow
for free okay it's a digital download
you're not gonna get the hard copy but
you know it's an interesting read and
you know you could learn something but
before we begin
just a brief disclaimer you know do you
know we're all adults here right we do
understand that trading is risky risk
capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's
financial security or lifestyle okay
you know sometimes people don't
understand that they think you know
trading is easy you know i see
you know especially during the pandemic
you know everyone was sitting around in
home
then we had that big v-shape recovery
and you know 12-year-old kids are making
you know the moms are posted online oh
my son is such a great stock investor
when you know they just caught the
market at the right time
now
when i was first introduced to a
footprint chart right this is a
footprint chart an order flow chart i
thought you know this is stupid you know
what is all this there's a lot of
numbers you know honestly i i was never
a big numbers person even in school and
you know when i
joined
jp morgan you know i thought
god you know
they gave me a nice offer and all that
and you know part of me was thinking i i
don't want to be sitting around talking
about yield curve analysis and all that
sort of stuff but
it really was it's really not like that
you know that's what sometimes people
get so caught up in thinking that the
financial world is like you know it's
it's not and the same thing with a
footprint chart right you see a lot of
numbers and it's easy to think you know
get lost and say i don't want to deal
with these numbers
well i'm going to show you you don't
have to right really all the numbers
that you see here are just records of
the trades that have happened and again
you know one of the reasons why a lot of
traders are scared of going to
a footprint chart is because
sorry excuse me
they think it's too hard to read
okay
i'm sorry for coughing here you know
it's like looking at hieroglyphics
for a lot of people because it's like oh
my gosh you know i don't understand what
these different numbers are you know
there's numbers on the left side on the
right side
some are blue some are red
there's different volumes going through
you know it's just too much for them to
to digest but once you understand what
it is you know what each number
represents
it really makes sense you know because
be honest when i first went to the
trading floor
back in the 90s you know
that's what fascinate you know that's
what draws a lot of people to the
training floors is they see all this
energy
and you know a lot of people yelling and
screaming but it's very precise
everyone people are talking to people
it's not just any you know it's not just
like a room full of kindergarten kids
where they just all run around yelling
screaming no the communication between
traders is
you know on point it's you know a
traitor
in the pit you know has this clerk who's
talking to someone on the phone you know
it it's all little conversations and all
you know once you understand it once you
spend
you know a half a day on the floor then
you really understand what's going on
and
it's not chaotic at all
so
as i spent more time with the footprint
chart you know because it came out i
don't know around you know 2005 or so
2006 and sort of different variations
even though they had been talk since the
80s of sort of analyzing volume in that
way
market really made
more sense to me rather than just
looking at time and sales or
you know the depth of the market
basically the trading dome
and
there was just really so much
information that was just like
you know open up a pandora's box so to
speak
i'm sorry
i got this cough
you know just yesterday okay market had
its nice 40 point move up
and
if you're looking at a normal
candlestick chart right you just see
this market going sideways and then boom
it just takes off to the races rallies
40 points
but if
you see down here right because you
don't know we're just sort of in a tight
trading range you know people you know
they'll draw their trend channels or
they'll draw their support resistance
levels but if you can see something
happening down here when we're training
around 4 300 42.95
in the order flow you're going to be
able to position yourself for this move
as early as possible rather than saying
well you know we finally broke out of
this range you know up here 4315.
you know or you know even up here around
4320 you know you're getting in
at the ground floor so to speak
and why is that important is because
the earlier you get into a move
the tighter stop you're going to have so
imagine right if you if you're drawing a
you know sort of a range here right
you'll call this double top right a lot
of people say well we got to break this
double top first before we break out
okay
well
that's at 43 4310 right where you're
gonna have your stop you know well it's
gonna be down here you know below this
swing low here at 42.95 so you got also
now you got a 15-point stop but
if you could be getting in for a reason
between 4 300 4305
you just cut your risk in half
okay you your stop is still going to be
somewhere down here on 42.95 but you're
only getting in at 4 300 you know 4305
rather than 43 10 43 15.
so you know that's how order flow is
going to help you right it's going to
help you tighten your risk levels right
instead of having such wide risk levels
you know it's going to give you a much
better stop placement
and you know with the order flow chart
you can understand what's happening in
the market right this is
that low there that i just showed you on
this chart right in here
right and if you're looking at that on
the order flow
well you can see the market is starting
to you know buyers are coming in
now
how can you tell well you could be
looking at
only talk about it in a minute
delta imbalances points of control that
are giving you the clues
that the aggressive buyers are coming
into the market that hey you know what
you know it's probably worth buying it
somewhere in here around 4301 4302
i don't think you get in at 4 300. but
your stop is just down here 42 90 you
know this low is like 96 and a quarter
you know so you just have to stop at 95.
right rather than waiting for this
market to sort of break out be trading
up here at 43 10 43 15 before you decide
to get long
all right so you're getting in you know
ten points earlier
than everybody else but your st your
risk is still the same level
now
gone are the glory days of pit trading
where you know
where traders paid hundreds of thousands
of dollars for exchange memberships and
why did they pay that much money is so
they can see the order flow as it occurs
you know they could see the big orders
coming into the market from the big
banks the big traders
you know the guys on the floor they're
smart you know even though
even though they don't have
um you know a lot of them just you know
have high school degrees everyone thinks
well you only got a high school degree
no these guys were sharp you know even
you know they they would know where the
big traders
cleared their trades through you know
they knew who soros used as their broker
they knew who tudor used as their broker
and if that broker was all of a sudden
checking the market
getting active
then they're going to participate right
and
as an off the floor trader you don't
have access to that information but now
that it's all electronic
it's become anonymous
but for traders for
you and me and everybody else sort of
the playing field has been leveled in
terms of overflow because now we can see
when the big orders are coming in right
because before when it was just the
trading floor you would just see the
numbers printing on your screen
you wouldn't see the volume you wouldn't
know if you know
the market traded a certain price if it
was heavy volume or light volume it was
just it traded that price you know
that's how because people
traders in a sense became price centric
you know they treated all prices the
same when not all prices
are the same
so
that leads me to the first point you'll
learn how to read the market and you
know honestly what does that mean read
the market well it just isn't cards
right you're trying to read the other
players tells you know what are they
doing you know are they do they think
they have a strong hand or a weak hand
right and you could tell that with the
market now yesterday
in the e in the es right the e-minis
if you're looking at
a normal candlestick chart you don't
understand why the market re you know
went up here and then sold off and then
rallied back up and eventually sold off
again
right because if you're just following
price
you're really leaving out a lot of
information right you're leaving out
what the aggressive traders are doing
you know is there passive traders you
know which is resting liquidity in the
order book
um you know how aggressive are traders
being
you know is their price acceptance is
their price rejection
and for a lot of traders you know they
just look at a chart after the fact and
say oh yeah this was a this is a great
sell here because of such-and-such but
as it's trading
right you want to be able to decide
oh there's price weakness here or
there's price support down here rather
than looking at after the fact and say
oh yeah you know i could see we got this
double top here we should have sold off
but you can
how many times have you seen the market
hit a double top and then pause and then
just keep going up you know you want to
be able to understand what's happening
in the market
and that is where using the order flow
allows you to see what the market is
doing
based on the actual activity of what's
trading in the market
right because now you can see how
aggressive buyers are being how
aggressive sellers are being you know is
someone coming into the market with
supply
is someone coming in to support the
market you know you can't tell that just
by looking at a normal
bar chart or candlestick chart
now order flow has three main data
points there's delta point of control
and imbalance
now when i say three data points these
are not the only data points but these
are the main ones right and you know
from them you have other data as max
delta min delta
now there's value areas
but there's a lot of different ways you
can
use this information so just really
briefly you know delta is the difference
between the aggressive buying and
aggressive selling in a bar now every
bar is going to have a delta right it's
going to be either positive or negative
or on
rare occurrences it'll be zero right
where just everything just is evenly
matched okay
so when you see a bar that's got
positive delta
you know like here positive 905. it's
telling you that aggressive buyers were
in control of
that bar okay that's all doesn't say
buyers are in control of the market
right now it's just telling you in that
bar
buyers are in control if you have
negative delta it's telling you
aggressive sellers were more dominant in
that bar okay so
from that information you can start to
put together pieces as to what is
happening in the market now point of
control
every bar has a point of control okay
and it's going to be highlighted usually
you're going to have a
rectangle around that price level
and it's where the most volume occurs in
the bar when you add up the volume
trading on the bid the volume traded on
the offer now
the market's trading a two-way auction
there's always a bid there's always an
offer
okay but point-of-control just measures
it at a price level
okay
so
oftentimes when you see a market
trending down you're going to see lower
points of controls the mark each bar is
going to be putting in a lower point of
control
okay
as the market is going sideways point of
control is going to be more or less
around the same level if a market is
rallying generally you're going to see
point of controls migrating higher
now imbalances now not every bar is
going to have imbalances because
what an imbalance is it's
it's the difference
between the aggressive buying and
aggressive selling in the two-way
auction right so on the bid versus the
offer
by a ratio of
usually four to one you know some people
use different ratios some people use ten
to one some people use three to one but
you know sort of the industry standard
so to speak
and you know the starting point for most
traders is four to one so when you see
blue numbers
in a bar in the footprint that is
a buying imbalance
when you see a red number in the bar
that is a selling about like
32 versus 165 right here in this red bar
that's a selling imbalance because when
the market was you know
43 14 and a quarter at a half they
traded 165 on the bid only 32 on the
offer
you know up here when it was uh 16 and a
quarter 16 and a half it traded 35 on
the bid 140 on the offer so you have
more aggressive buying than aggressive
selling in the two-way auction here just
as down here with the sound and balance
you have more aggressive selling than
aggressive buying in the two-way auction
and
generally speaking
as the market is selling off you're
gonna you're gonna see
selling imbalances
more selling imbalances than buying and
balances there will be some buying
balances scattered in because you know
what this market's selling off people
are going to take profits right they're
just going to
lift the offer get out of their position
just as a market that's going up
starting to rally
you're going to see buying imbalances
so remember right the market is always
right
and
if the market is always right
then why don't you just follow what the
market is showing you
right why you gotta try and fight what
the market is doing you know that's
where a lot of traders
run into problems is
they
try to fight the market right and at the
end of the day they're going to lose
okay
it's
you know
we can sit here and do all the analysis
that we want
and say oh you know what every
everything i got you know all my
indicators you know every analysis form
of analysis i did said the market's got
to go up
so you get long and what happens the
market sells off well
if you hold on to that position you're
probably going to get railroaded
but the market is going up and you're
you know sorry if you you know you think
the market is going up but the market is
selling off because all your tools that
you have is telling you that the market
should go up but if it doesn't
remember
you're not the market the market is out
there if
the market is doing something of than
what you think it's doing and you're
there fighting it you're gonna be
holding the bag so to speak you know
you're just gonna lose money why don't
you just do what the market is showing
you is trying to do if the market you
know regardless whether you got 100
indicators and 100 of them all say the
market is going up but the market is
selling off
you should be going in the direction of
the market right if it's selling off you
go short
so that's where order flow is going to
help you right it's going to keep you on
the right side of the market
and once you understand order flow once
you look more closely you'll see how
much activity you never noticed before
you're going to notice accumulation
you're going to notice distribution
you're going to notice
absorption you're gonna see where trap
traders are you're gonna see where
supportive buying comes into the market
where resistant selling comes into the
market and and so much more you know
it's one thing to look at a bar chart
after the market closes
and say oh yeah you know there was trap
traders at this level um you know here's
accumulation here
as opposed to in real time that's what
order flow allows you to to understand
is happening is see this stuff happening
in real time
and
basically take advantage of it right
because that's what you want to do right
you want to trade smarter
with the order flow
and once you understand how to read the
information generated by the market
then you can trade smarter because you
can be in sync with
how the market is trading and you're
going to feel more confident so you know
back to our e-mini chart from yesterday
okay
you know
excuse me we had this nice sell-off here
right from 43-18
basically down to 42.80 you know almost
a quick 40-point sell-off here right in
the first half hour of trading
what would you do right coming into that
this was
this was the
the chart here leading into it right i
mean it look it's just it just shot up
right after the cash open sort of going
sideways
okay
well
are we going to still go higher or are
we going to start selling off and if
you're looking at the order flow and you
start looking at the delta the poc the
imbalances well
you're going to start to see things that
other traders aren't noticing until the
market really starts selling off right
it's going to help you get in earlier up
near
the start of the move rather than after
the moves already you know halfway over
but if you're looking here
right you can see the delta what's
happening in the delta let's take a look
okay so remember the market had just
shot up now it's going sideways okay you
got this bar here this green candle nice
big positive delta 905.
then the next bar positive delta 179
next bar positive delta of 70 next bar
negative delta 143. so
we're up here at the high after the cash
opened it's not the height of the day
it's a high of since the cash opened
and buying was was fairly strong right
you remember to rally right you're gonna
need some strong aggressive buying right
back here you got 1500 is the delta
but then it just goes sideways and
delta's kind of you know nothing special
right plus 200 minus 300 minus 200 plus
300 plus 100
minus 200 minus 188
plus 200 then plus 900 okay yeah maybe
we're going higher you know you see some
signs of aggression here nice aggressive
buying it got some imbalances but then
no follow-through 179
70 on some red candles that's not good
right okay so you're seeing the market
getting weaker here
because for this market to go higher
you're going to need strong positive
delta not delta getting weaker so
instead of getting stronger it's getting
weaker as the market starts falling over
right
what's pocs doing
well pocs on the bar with the nice big
positive delta is way up here 43 16.
next bar it's at 43 15. bar after that
you know 14 next bar 43-13
pocs are starting to migrate lower so
it's telling you you know the the
major volume the level with the most
volume in each bar is going
down
that's not a sign of a market that's
going up right if a market was strong
and is rallying right you'll be seeing
volume migrate higher not volume migrate
lower
because after all what causes the volume
well it's traders that are happy to
transact at that price and if people are
also now happy to transact at lower
prices
that's a sign that you know maybe this
market's going to start to sell off
which it did
right so instead of
you know waiting for this market to
start breaking down in here you know a
lot of people say well you know we got
this candle down here we got to break
this wick and get short down here 42.98
no you can be short from up here 43-16
where's your stop
just above this high
right so instead of getting short way
down here 4305 4306 4300 you're short at
the beginning of the move
right and again it's not like it's
that big a leap in faith because you're
understanding what's happening in the
market you understand that
the aggressive buying is just not there
anymore and now we're starting to see
aggressive selling
imbalances honestly not so much in here
i mean you got one here one here but
it's not strong
yet until you start really selling off
but the signs were very clear in the
delta in the points of control
then you sell off right from that 4316
area you come down here to the 42
you know 82 42 84 level then you rally
back up again to where where you just
were
but
in the order flow what are you looking
for right again you know i was talking
about the points of control right i was
looking for imbalances looking at the
delta okay so as you're coming down
you got this big bar here right with big
negative delta minus 2300
okay that's bearish yeah okay market
continues minus 900.
and then you see positive delta 300.
then okay a little bit more solid minus
and you see positive 900 positive 168
positive 223 positive 1300 positive 900.
now you're starting to see points of
controls sort of start to go up here you
got you know one two three higher
came off a little bit here in these two
bars now 37 negative delta
even though it's got negative delta
right it's just 37
which is pretty much neutral right so
even though it's a red candle and it's
down you know i see this delta of -37
i don't read too much into it right the
next bar minus 475 is this is a decent
number
okay well let's wait and see you know is
there going to be more selling or more
buying coming in well no you see more
buying coming in
okay
you see positive delta 4
um sorry 590. so what else do you see
right you see one two three four five
six binding balances in this bar right
off this swing low right points controls
moving higher
this bar i just sort of treat as neutral
this bar okay you know it's a red candle
doesn't mean that this whole this rally
is not going to happen
and
then the next bar nice green candle
point of control a little bit lower
close up well above the point of control
obviously if you know if we hold quarter
control is going to be higher again
so you could be looking to get long
somewhere in here in this bar
um
you know anywhere in this bar 42 90 to
42 93 you know y'all you know even at
the end of the bar 42.95
right right in here
you'll be getting long so
you have to position yourself for this
move back up
right rather than waiting for it to
break out of you know whatever level
here sort of come back up you could
catch this move and again you know
where's your stop is just down here
right you're you know where your risk is
right if you're getting long in here
4290 you know 4280 is your your stop
level rather than waiting for it to sort
of break out of this you know this
little pullback high up here at 4296 you
get in much earlier
but you should be able to see that the
aggressive buying is coming in in the
deltas right in the imbalances right
that's what you're looking for sort of
get a a better picture because if this
market was going to keep going down
you're not going to see this strong
aggressive buying coming in right you're
going to see more bars with strong
negative delta
not strong positive delta
right markets don't rally on strong i'm
sorry markets don't rally on strong
negative delta they rally on strong
positive delta
right and you don't see other than this
these three bars here
with strong negative delta you don't
necessarily see that you see 1 bar minus
600 but there's plus 900 plus 1300 plus
it's got more of a shot to rally than to
continue down
so hopefully by now this is starting to
make sense right that you can see how
easy reading the order flow is right it
really all it is it's just common sense
thinking so let's take a look at the
at the rally back up right we came all
the way back up to 43 18 right then we
sold off again okay so
hopefully by now you can start to see
what's happening right remember this
market had just rallied from you know
the 4280 area back up to you know 43 15
43 16 43 18. and just sort of holding
steady there okay you don't know is this
market going to break to the downside or
is it going to keep going to the upside
but if you're looking again at
what's happening in the order flow
it's just going sideways
okay and do you really see anything one
way or the other in the order flow not
really right you don't see strong really
strong aggressive buying to take this
market back up
you just see
you know kind of smallish deltas one way
or the other you know negative 400
positive 400 positive 400
positive 193 minus 252 minus
you know plus 100 plus 56 plus 70 then
minus 749
okay
if this market is going to rally
you want to see some nice solid positive
deltas plus 600 plus 800 plus a thousand
now
you know every market is different this
is the es if you're looking at something
like
um crude oil you know the numbers would
be different but you got to understand
your market now
you know in crude oil if you see plus
400 that would be big but on e-mini is
on a one-minute chart that's just you
know nothing special
but then you start seeing in here well
you see the delta's minus just plus 100
plus 56 plus 70. you know that's a sign
already even though you know this market
is just sort of going sideways
the buying is just not there anymore
and if the buying is not there anymore
what do you think the market's going to
do
it's going to fall over right because
there's nobody there to support this
market you don't necessarily need to
have strong negative delta
as long as you don't have strong
positive delta you know good positive
delta the market's going to sell off
which it did
so again you know just follow what the
market is doing right
you and i you know we may be smarter
than the trader of goldman sachs or jp
morgan you know i know a lot of these
guys you know trust me
they're not rocket scientists you know
some of them are just
good at trading but at the end of the
day
they have something you and i don't have
they have very deep pockets and trying
to fight with them is going to be an
uphill battle
right we just we're just not going to
win those battles
now
you know the third part that i want to
talk about is understanding what's
happening in the market based on what's
trading right now because remember right
we have to base our trading decisions
off of what is happening right now we
don't want to say be making trading
decisions based on things that happened
yesterday
or the day before i mean you know on
different types of trading strategies
okay that might be good but if you're
trading order flow the best time to take
advantage of it is right now based on
what's happening if you're basing your
training decisions on what's happening
right now
you got to do it be like me saying hey
let's go fishing where would you rather
fish right the the place where the fish
are literally just jumping out of the
water into the boat
or the area where everybody's in there
with a net trying to scoop up the fish
well it's going to be better
to go to the area where the fish are
just jumping out of the water into your
boat it's going to be a lot easier
and trading is the same way
right if you have a way to sort of catch
these fish that are just jumping out of
the water into the boat you're gonna be
ahead of everybody else that's over you
know in the area that's that's being
overfished
now this morning in the es right the
market just went on a tear this morning
you know once cash open it just it
literally went parabolic right it looks
like a bitcoin chart or something like
that you know we just jumped up from
43.86 all the way up to you know above 4
400 and
you know if you're looking at the chart
you know it's one of those moves that
you wish you could catch as as early as
possible
but if you're looking at
a footprint chart
you could really start to see signs of
what's happening early now
remember earlier i explained
the order flows trader software right
how it helps a trader
do analysis for them
all right because when i when i started
trading with order flow way back when a
decade ago whenever
basically this was the overflow chart
right you had your delta your max delta
your min delta your cumulative delta
your volume and you'd have your point of
control your imbalances
now these numbers above and below bars
are
are ratios of order flow especially the
measurement of order flow
but this was it
and there were certain things that i
would look for in the order flow that
would be bullish or bearish
and
you know i found a programmer the reason
why it's not a ninjatrader 8
is because you know
back in the mid
teens you know 2014 2015 whenever um
the software
choices as far as you know i'm not a
programmer and
the um program that i really found was
you know some guy that
you know we're good friends now he
really understands overflow as well you
know he programmed for ninjatrader okay
so that's why my software is on
ninjatrader and it's not like on think
or swim or trade station so
there were certain things i would look
for in the order flow right so remember
right this market just went parabolic
right in here from this 43
you know basically you know 87 area 88
shot up immediately over the next 10
minutes you know 15
handles almost 20 handles
but if you're looking at the order flow
you know
you want to get in as early as possible
right you want to take advantage of that
overflow now i was talking a bit about
delta
i was talking about these imbalances
you know you can see this is a stacked
imbalance here
but there's other things in here right
now you could add things like the value
areas right you can see the value areas
on the box this is from my software with
a lot of the tools turned on the order
flows trader has extra tools to help you
do order flow analysis so you can
understand really understand what's
happening in the market now
looking at this on my order for traders
chart right it might be a little bit
hard to see on your screen but this is
actually a blue box here which is
bullish this is a blue box here which is
bullish as opposed to just the normal
box which is gray
if it was bearish it would be a red
color
and in here we got a very bullish point
of control as opposed to just your
normal point of control so i can see
signs in here in the order flow when
we're trading down here 43.86 43.88
that this market
is getting ready to
i don't say pump but go higher i i
didn't imagine it to just
parabolic move all the way up to you
know 06 immediately
from you know 86 area
but this is sort of the things you see
in the order flow over and over and
that's why
you know i put all this these tools into
the order flows trader is because you
know i like to look at more than one
market
and you know if i'm looking at more than
one market i want to be able to take
some of that analysis burden off me and
let the software do it so i could know
at a glance by just looking at my screen
hey you know what i got some bullish
information in here let's pay attention
to this market
and trade it because you know what i'd
rather be getting in somewhere in here
around you know the 88 area 89 90 rather
than waiting for it to break out to the
new highs above you know 99 or 400
i could get in
very fast and because you know and the
beauty part of it is i know where to
place my stop right just below this sort
of this area in here
where the bullish order flow started
because if i have bullish order flow
coming in at a certain area
and the market starts training below it
well
that bullish order flow
obviously didn't work and you're not
going to hold up a bullish position
if you start getting past your bullish
order flow right you just won't
now crude oil this is yesterday right we
hit this low 7712
then we rallied you know immediately up
to you know 60 came off a bit and
rallied back up to 80.
but again you know as you're coming into
a
high or a low in this case
you should be asking yourself you know
is this low going to hold and you can
see here it hit there you know one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
times before it rallied
but if you're looking at the order flow
you can start to see the same signs in
here that i just showed you on the crude
oil right you have your bullish value
area you have your bullish point of
control
you see other signs in here
what
might be again it might be a little bit
hard to see on your screen
but there is a
sign of market exhaustion appearing
right in here with this five lots traded
right it's telling you the market keeps
pounding in here 55 106 58 79 43 90 13
104 and then just five
where's the selling you know all the
sellers everyone kept pounding into it
sell sell sell
and they just gave up at this point and
once they start giving up that's a sign
that the market is going to reverse i
mean you also have bullish signs in here
earlier you know with this value area
with this point of control obviously you
got some divergences in here
and you know it's it's really a low-risk
trade you know you're getting in
somewhere in you know anywhere you know
20 22 with a stop just below 12.
you're risking 10 ticks
you know for what you know the move went
all the way up to 60.
right everyone says oh you gotta have a
risk reward ratio of two to one minimum
three to one minimum well here you are
you're getting long at you know 20 with
a stop at 10 it's only 10 ticks
rather than you know a lot of people
will wait for the breakout of the recent
swing high before they get long you know
they'll draw the line here and they're
getting long at 40 well the market after
that point the market only moved another
20 ticks
right the area to be getting long is
down here right as the market is
breaking out of this area
now another feature right which i didn't
talk about this is still the same crude
oil is the imbalances
right and you can see in here
you're seeing
one
this bar's got one two three imbalances
this bar's got one two three four
imbalances this bar's got one two three
imbalances and the software you know
even though these are not nicely stacked
you know most order flow traders
are used to
looking at
you know stacked imbalances that
imbalances that are bunched together one
on top of each other you know three or
more
but when you still have three or more
imbalances even if they're spread out in
the bar it's still a bullish sign and
you can see here you know it's like
there was aggressive buying here just
couldn't pull up now suddenly you got
more aggressive buying coming in here in
the form of three imbalances that's why
there's this magenta box around it
magenta box around this bar magenta box
even around this bar more aggressive
buying so you know that there's
aggressive buying coming in at the low
of the day what do you think that means
well it means people think that this is
a good buying opportunity because now
they're aggressive
you know they're showing their hand
right there they're aggressively buying
this market
right so you know being able to identify
these at a glance right now again this
is not rocket science right you're just
looking at
one two three imbalances okay putting it
together and understanding what's
happening we're at the low of the day
we're seeing a lot of aggressive buying
coming in that's bullish for the market
right but again if you're just looking
at a bar chart you're not noticing that
aggressive buying
now this is buns today all right we are
sorry yesterday the seventh
okay what are we
oh sorry this is the sixth
um we hit that high just around ten
o'clock
and it sort of went sideways and then
fell over about 20 20 ticks okay well
what's in the overflow that's that's
going to tell you now you know people
say well you got a bullish engulfing
pattern you know
et cetera well just before you had a
bullish engulfing pattern to the upside
but the market didn't go up it sold off
you know
people that trade candlesticks i i used
to be a big candlestick guy
and
you know honestly when they worked they
were the perfect excuse for why the
market went in a direction but like you
said you know people say well this got
this market sold off because you got
this bearish engulfing pattern
okay well why didn't the market rally
because you got a bullish engulfing
pattern immediately before it
so you know when they work they're the
great greatest thing ever but a lot of
times they don't work you know honestly
they work about half the time you know
some work more than others but if you're
looking at the order flow
right it just really makes sense to you
you know this is the high of the day
here at 92 sort of came off
started to rally back up sort of poke a
little bit higher you see market
exhaustion one contracts trade right the
market is trying to go back up to test
this high but you can only draw on one
more trader trade one contract
it's a five minute chart right
buns are very liquid market all right
but only one contract traded come on
what's going on maybe just nobody's
interested in buying it
then you see the aggressive selling
coming in imbalance imbalance imbalance
right a nice big negative delta
what do you see up here right as the
market's going sideways you see point of
controls
just lined up right just going sideways
okay
and then lower point of control lower
point of control okay you'll be getting
short somewhere in here around 80
even in this bar
market sold off a little bit started a
rally up and two contracts trade
market's not going to rally if only two
people buy it
right or one person buys two contracts
right if market's gonna rally you're
gonna buy 600 then buy another 700 here
another 500 here
there's no more buying people aren't
interested in taking this market any
higher
obviously you got the negative delta
you know you just hit the high 844
positive delta then immediately
afterwards you got negative 631. then
187 negative
positive 805. okay maybe this market
still got some buying it we could go
higher then it comes in big strong
negative delta minus 938 it's not a good
sign no positive delta 300
and then the selling just comes right in
boom minus 1100
minus 100
plus 900 okay maybe this market can
start to rally maybe not minus 300 minus
minus five
you know anytime you see some buying
coming in it's pretty sporadic
and it's followed up by a lot more
selling
so again you know you could be getting
shorted here around 78 80 in here in
these couple bars
you know it's just a stop
right up here somewhere right you know
this area we had aggressive sellers if
we're going to come back up here and
test it maybe these aggressive sellers
will be back in there right you sort of
have a resistance area formed in here
with all these points and controls lined
up
if you can get above 85 maybe it'll
it'll start to rally but right now if
you're short at 82 you have an area
right here you could hide behind around
and what happens is the market sells off
from the 80s all the way down into the
60s
okay yes right this was
you know you see markets right they
rotate they go down they go up they pull
back a little bit go back up okay well
don't you want to understand why the
market pulled back here to this level
people say well you know you got a pin
bar there well it's not really a pin bar
because it's not really a low right it's
just you know it's a low within the last
four bars but
it's not really
but if you're looking at the order flow
you can understand
you know this is one of the tools that
we have in the order flow trader to
analyze what's happening in the delta
for you
right the market had been rallying
okay then you get a little bit of a
pullback so you got what happens in a
pullback you have selling coming in
okay
well you got selling coming in but is
that selling strong or weak because if
it's strong it's going to sell off some
more
if it's weak it's going to stop and it's
going to reverse and go back up and this
is you know what we have in the software
called the the market weakness detector
and it's telling you that this little
pullback the selling is weakening here
right because you know markets going up
you got nice positive delta
you know 500 300 and then
negative delta
negative delta negative delta
and positive delta so it's telling you
the delta even though you got negative
delta it's getting weaker here minus 500
minus 177 minus 73.
green candle okay the selling is over it
was just a little bit of profit taking
maybe you know the market had just
rallied from 44
up to 50
you know so maybe some of these people
are getting long in here you know are
taking their profits
and and once they're done taking their
profits you know selling it out then the
market's probably going to keep rallying
up
all right because you got to understand
what's the rotation in the e-minis
you know there's about four or five
points so
it starts to make sense on why this
market pulled back here and you can see
it
in the order flow
okay
gold
all right this was
the sixth right the day or two ago right
markets hit the high then sold off and
just sort of went sideways in here okay
now
what are some of the signs in the market
right well if you're looking at the
order flow
again market sold off from the high it's
sort of coming down here
what do you see you still see some
selling right you see this bar's got
four imbalances this bar's got four
imbalances okay maybe this market can
sell off some more but in order for it
to sell off you're gonna want to see
aggressive more aggressive selling
coming in and you don't see it in fact
you see the opposite you see aggressive
selling coming in but it's getting
weaker right you have a nice strong
negative delta of 143 then you got
positive delta positive delta positive
delta positive delta
a nice strong negative delta 89
another negative delta 59 which is
you know decent
and then you got
negative delta of three
then positive delta 32 you know one you
know what can you do with one then eight
but
instead of seeing more selling coming in
you see the selling actually getting
weaker in this case it's not so much of
um
seeing strong buying coming in what
you're seeing is the selling getting
weaker
right again you know we all like to
focus on you know what moves the markets
you know the aggressive buying
or the aggressive selling you know
that's what's going to move a market
lowers aggressive selling what's going
to move a market higher is aggressive
buying
but if
that aggressiveness
is weakened
it's not going to keep going in that
direction right and that's what order
flow allows you to see
so hopefully
you can see how powerful order flow
analysis is you know honestly you know i
you know on youtube i got about 250
videos covering many different aspects
of order flow you know i wish i could
cover everything today but i just don't
have the time and
you know there's just so many
interesting things in the order
literally every day
um
you know the best piece of advice i give
you is to trade what's happening right
in front of you so if you found this
helpful and you know if if you saw the
charts that i used right which are
generated by the order flows trader 3.0
package
you know i got a special deal for you
it's going to make it easy
you know don't over complicate trading
you know as humans we like to over
complicate things right you don't have
to do that you know you just trade using
common sense you know the best computer
is the one on your shoulders right your
brain you know now orderful analysis
provides a trader advanced information
that's going to give them an edge over
other traders right that's why i talk
about when you know going fishing do you
want to be fishing in the spot where all
the fish are jumping into your boat or
going to the spot everybody else is
fishing
hardly
yeah i don't know what percentage your
percentage is going up people that use
order flow analysis but it's still quite
low you know a lot of traders are just
focused on price they're focused on
using um
indicators that manipulate price right
they're not taking into account what's
happening
in the actual trading volumes that's
going through right because if you're
treating every price that trades the
same
you're gonna be at a disadvantage
because you know if
a thousand contracts trade at one price
and five contracts traded at another
they got completely different meanings
depending on where it comes in the
market structure
so order flow analysis allows you to see
and understand what's happening in the
markets that other traders don't see you
know don't want to
make trading complicated you want to
keep it simple
now there's two ways you can do it right
you can do it on your own you can spend
a year looking at a screen
trying to figure out overflow but more
importantly you're gonna waste a year
losing more
time and more money honestly trading
trying to figure it out you know when i
ask you how's it going next year you're
getting a thumbs up okay great or until
you get the education
and software from a trader
who has successfully traded order flow
at the highest levels for decades you
know that's why i went over sort of i
don't like to show you my resume to be
bragging or anything like that but i
want you to understand
where i'm coming from
how i learned it and why i want to teach
it to you right because yeah at the end
of the day it's about giving back you
know there's no more trading floor where
anybody could just come to the exchange
and basically get a job as a runner
those days don't exist anymore to get a
job at a trading firm you got to have a
degree from the top level university in
math or programming you know the the
entrance to trading has changed
so you know i want you to skip the
massive trading losses but more
importantly skip the wasted time
so
the order flows trader 3.0 which is
available
charting platform you can execute trades
on any platform
um you know i have a lot of users that
actually use the free version they just
get a data feed a real-time data feed
you need that
and
they execute through their existing
broker
so again it works on ninjatrader 8 and
it's the volume footprint chart that
comes with 17 pre-programmed order flow
indicators i talked about you know
market weakness i think i talked about
value area briefly
the imbalances in the bars but it gives
you so much more than that you know
again i wish i could go over every one
of them today but i just can't and
you're going to get as i said my chart
template but the way the chart is set up
once you load it onto your pc
it's defaulted for a one-minute e-mini
chart so depending on the market you
know you might want to make a couple
adjustments normally i sell it for 8.99
which is really a great deal
you know there's other software it sells
for a couple thousand dollars but you
don't need to waste that money you know
i like to keep the barrier to entry low
but i realize having order flow software
is one thing the next thing is you don't
know how to use it so i just give you
the software and send you on your way i
provide a lot of education on how to
trade with order folks to me that's
really the important part is knowing how
to trade order flow not just having
software that can analyze the order flow
you got to know
that
there's no red light green light system
really in the market
because every situation is slightly
different so
each week right for users of my software
i do a private live group training
session
for everybody it's tuesday night 7 p.m
and you know we've got i just finished
episode 139 so it's every week so you
can imagine episode 139 that goes back
how many years over two years
and you know some places some gurus
there's gurus gurus and gurus
they charge extra for their training why
you know you're making that investment
making that decision
to learn something
it should be included in there you
should have to pay extra to learn how to
use the software
so you know that's why i do the live
session so you could come in any
questions you have you know problems
with setting it up or anything i'm there
every week you know unless it's like a
holiday or something or i got some last
minute
emergency that i have to cancel it but
again you can see i'm on episode 139 so
obviously this has been going on for how
many years
um
it's there for you to ask questions if
you don't ask questions i was going to
talk about interesting things i saw on
the order flow
and you know hopefully you can learn
something because really it's not about
making you a clone of me it's giving you
ideas that you can take and improve your
trading
you know it doesn't just because you use
order flows i mean you have to disregard
everything you've ever learned about
trading no you could add order flow and
improve the current weight you're
trading
so i'm also going to give you access to
my order flows trading course which i
sell for 297 on my website you know
people buy this almost every day
and you can get it for free okay but not
only that you're also going to get
access to
this video series i did i used to have
an inner circle for traders i paid a lot
of money for this and
these are just the videos which there's
56 videos on you know sort of advanced
order flow tips analysis and i say
tricks but you know just really ways to
analyze the overflow that you never
thought possible so you start adding
that up and
you know the software the training the
universal inner circle video series the
weekly group training you know it's
already sixteen hundred dollars which
already is in my opinion is a bargain
and as a bonus all right i'm even gonna
give you access to my order flows
playbook which is
a little course i did one of my favorite
courses on a sort of advanced order flow
right and you know i even give you
10 setups that you can go look for in
the order flow are you going to get this
access to this for free today as well
and normally i sell this for you know
everything together it's almost two
thousand dollars right that's not even
including the weekly live group training
because you only get access to the
weekly group training
if you joined
with the software okay
now
to get started what you have to do is
you have to go to orderflows.com
off 3.html so you know other people are
saying like sheila says right mike your
order flow software is remarkably
helpful because i can clearly see now
what's really happening in the market
like for example who's in control of the
market on very specific times
you know and who's getting weaker as
well because you know at the end of the
day
that's what you want to do right you
want to understand who's in charge
of the market okay you want to
understand you know are traders
getting uh stronger or weaker you know
you want to understand really basically
the market okay
you know other people's ad you know
you know i really want to trade properly
and understand what earth's happening in
the markets or order flow is the path
forward mike's experience and
explanation it clicks right
so
you know to get started go to
orderflows.com3.html so
again it's
up to you to make it happen i can't
twist your arm and say oh you know you
got to buy my software i want you to
become a better trader you got to do it
this way you got to make that decision
you got to make that that leap and again
it's just a one-time payment
of 7.49 so you can get all that stuff
right you're going to get the
software you're going to get
the order flow training course you're
going to get
a workflow playbook you get the
order flow inner circle video series
and
you get access to join the live group
training sessions that meets tuesday
nights
there's no monthly payments you know
it's not something i'm going to charge
you 7.49 a month for or anything like
that it's just a one-time payment so
some of these things you got to go oh
you know i can't cancel those payments
anymore you know it's like you know i've
bought these things sometimes it's like
you sign up and you try to cancel you
can't cancel it you got to
cancel your credit card somehow they
still bill you on the credit card that
even though you canceled it um no
none of that
games and anything it's just no monthly
pay you know you will have to pay for
data fees of course in a way around that
you need real-time data quote you know
and ninja trader fees you know if you're
using a paid version a ninja trader
and if you get a paid version
ninjatrader
then your commissions will be lower okay
so what you got to do is go to
orderflows.com3
dot html this is what page looks like
just scroll down or you can click on
that green button there it says get
instant access to order flows trader
takes you down to the bottom of the page
now on this page you see there's a lot
of videos you could watch um charts you
could take a look at so you understand
exactly what you're getting
and you can see it's a one-time payment
749 you get lifetime access to overflows
trader and
what that means is you know when we do
an upgrade
you can get access to the upgrade for
free right i don't charge you because we
do an upgrade now you can get access for
free you know i still got users that
bought the software in 2015 that are
still using it all right so i know it's
good i know it's stable
and you'll also get access to the order
flow trading course and access to the
overflow inner circle video series and
you get access to our weekly live group
trainings and i said also as a bonus
you're going to get access to
the order flow playbook okay because
it's not on here because it's a special
deal
that you're gonna get access to so it's
gonna save you an extra 300 bucks
and
once you click on that button right the
buy now button click here to buy now it
takes you to paypal paypal processes it
i don't get your
credit card information i don't want
your credit card information
i got other things to deal with
but
anybody that's ever bought anything
online understands what paypal is you
don't even need a paypal account you can
check out as a guest and just enter your
credit card details so
like i told you at the beginning if you
want a copy of my book trading order
flows
go to this page www.orderflows.com
book.html it's going to take you here
you have to enter your name
first name last name and email and click
submit
okay then you're gonna be put on a list
you know i will be sending you emails
from time to time
and then you're gonna after you hit
submit you're gonna be taken to
a page that
will take you to the download of the
ebook you can just save it to your
computer save it to your phone print it
out do whatever you want with it right
um but it's it's a good book i said it
took me
quite a while to write it and you know
honestly i had to wait after for at
least a year before i could start
writing it um
because when i left jp morgan they're
like oh you can't do anything for a year
et cetera i'm like come on
um
you know i don't want to start writing
this book then they'll come back well
that's jp morgan's property well screw
you guys but anyway go to
www.orderflows.combook.html
so
to get started go to
orderflows.com3.html to get the software
and all the
extra bonuses
and again you know thank you for taking
the time out today and coming to this
presentation you know there was one
question uh one or two questions let me
just take a look here real quick um
how long will it
it will take a student to learn
to be profitable well you know it really
depends on you know on the students you
know because i don't know how much time
you can commit to
looking at the markets or
you know trading you know some people
have full-time jobs um some people
will have all day long to
to spend doing it really depends on the
person
but you don't need 10 000 hours of
screen time
in my opinion you know honestly
you know
these firms these trading firms
if you're not profitable quickly
you're not going to have a job very long
so
i think most traders you know if you're
going to be successful kind of know it
early on
rather than you know i i see people say
i've been trading mike for 10 years and
i haven't been profitable
you know can you help me well yeah i
probably could but
you probably have some bad habits you
gotta you gotta lose so it really
depends on the person you know
um
there's no one right answer you know i
wish i could say yeah you know everybody
will be profitable well not everybody is
cut out for trading in all honesty you
know some people
you know like myself you know i can't be
a doctor or a nurse
because
you know cutting people open is not for
me you know and for some people putting
on a trade and risking just a few
hundred dollars
they can't handle it so you know
everyone has their own makeup and it
really just depends on the individual
but if you're
dedicated
and you really want to make it happen it
can happen pretty quick you know i don't
say a week two weeks
you know
i'd say give it at least 30 days to 90
days to see if trading is really for you
specifically if trading with order flow
is for you um because it's not something
that
you know train with order flow you got
to be in front of the screen
it's not something that you can look at
where the order flow is trading after
the day is over
and put your trades in like that like
like a swing trader no you know order
flow is is for um day traders right
people are in or out
in and out during the trading day
so
again you know thanks everybody let me
see
um you know thanks for taking the time
out today
and
that's all so any questions you know my
email is mike orderflows.com may take me
a day or two to get back to your email
because i do get
five six seven hundred emails a day and
um
again thanks for taking the time out
today and again to get started go to
orderflows.com3.html
so have a great day everybody bye bye
you